et maintenant un extrait une dédicace du
fond du coeur c'est pour vous un pascal
gmail musique qui j'espère mersen
[Musique]
séquences cultes regarder écouter
analyser c'est magique
[Musique]
m
les
et ce témoin
allez
dur
nouvelle
je vais
alors lui
mais
alors c'est qu'ils arrêtent à l'offre
mais si j'ai pas compris le je suis fou
de toi nabil abu la télé est un petit
show mais je ne savais pas mais ça s'est
passé la saison après j'étais parfois tu
sais quoi parce qu'ils n'ont pas vieilli
en plus je crois que c'est un truc
qu'ils avaient fait ton ex mes amis si
c'est pas mon meilleur ami sam très bon
pote et lucia les devants mais tu sais
pas celle qui me parle plus il a reconnu
quand même et j'ai cru que c'était après
à sarah que c'est pas que ça fait un
nouveau truc mais c'est bien c'est pour
la promo nordisk alors que l'armée avait
qui reverse tous les noms comme j'ai
toujours dis bravo
[Applaudissements]